hi my name is Jorge Samir with IBM cloud
and today I'm gonna be talking about
beem beem is an intelligent data
management backup and disaster recovery
solution that is focused on providing
hyper availability and uptime for their
customers backup and disaster recovery
is no longer a luxury but an absolute
necessity our consumers expect us to
stay online they want to be able to
access their products when they want it
however this is becoming much more
challenging with the rise of disasters
such as natural disasters the rise of
ransomware and cyber attacks and lastly
human errors maintaining this out time
and availability is becoming much much
more challenging many businesses have
their disaster recovery and backup
environment within their own datacenter
this is risky because if your data
center goes down you are down so as
companies begin to modernize they look
at their cloud to provide a disaster
recovery and backup environment some of
the benefits are the geographic spread
we're giving you that two hundred four
hundred five hundred mile difference to
ensure availability by a different
region also beyond that we provide a
variety of different economic benefits
because you don't need a disaster
recovery environment until you're going
through a test or an outage so within
the cloud you can use the flexibility to
have a low initial footprint and scale
up as needed to accommodate an outage
backup and disaster recovery is
completely different than availability
cloud service providers guarantee you a
certain level of availability of your
workloads but it doesn't mean that your
workloads are backed up and resilient
whether in your own datacenter cloud or
multi cloud environment you need
disaster recovery and backup beam on IBM
cloud is one option within IBM cloud we
give you full bare metal and hypervisor
access and this is important because it
significantly reduces the learning curve
of using the cloud this enables you to
maintain the same security flexibility
and control that you're running in your
own data center today specifically would
be you get access to all the advanced
functionality which really makes beem
beem such as instant
and recovery sure replicas sure backup
in a variety of other features it's
critical that businesses have deployment
flexibility as their requirements vary
by specific applications and workloads
in IBM cloud we have over 13,000
different deployments of Veen you can
either deploy on our virtual server
instances are non virtualized bare metal
as well as our VMware and s ap workloads
these deployment options are available
in sixty plus data centers around the
globe one of the really cool things is
you can actually replicate between these
data centers for free and securely so if
I think about backing up my own
workloads I have my production data
center in a and then my backup data
center envy so replicating between the
two is completely free and secure within
the IBM cloud and this really saves me a
significant amount of networking cost to
have a backup and disaster recovery
environment in the cloud in order to
meet your consumer expectation and
availability requirement you need a
multi cloud strategy
v-mon IBM cloud provides you the control
flexibility and availability to meet
your business objectives thank you for
watching if you have any questions
please comment below if you would like
to learn more about what IBM cloud is
doing please subscribe to our YouTube
channel